have you ever wondered why your favorite
on-screen couples have such steamy
chemistry
well a lot of the time they are actually
dating in real life
but not all romance ends with happily
ever after sometimes heartbreak is
inevitable
you won't believe some of these
on-screen couples who actually dated in
real life and others who you would think
were a match made in heaven
either way all these ended up with a
breakup let's begin
the pairing of betty and jughead on
riverdale was surprising at first
because both characters seemed so
different
but the chemistry between lily reinhardt
and cole sprouse was just too magnetic
and their attraction
couldn't be stopped that carried over in
real life too as the actors began a
passionate romance
off camera as well the couple
affectionately known as
bughead by fans began dating back in
2017
the same year the show first premiered
on the cw
and although the two always looked cute
together there's been rumors of trouble
in paradise in the past
year or so well now it's official cole
and lily have officially parted ways for
good this time
back in 2019 while some outlets reported
the two had broken up
lily took to twitter to tell everyone to
not believe everything they've read on
the internet
at the time that may have been true but
things have changed now
with the two having broken up privately
a few months ago
we just hope these two can still find a
way to work together riverdale is still
going strong and we can't imagine it
ending anytime
soon we'll have to see if the couple's
real-life breakup will affect the show
in any way joe jonas and demi lovato not
all breakups end in a messy way
sometimes two co-stars have a brief
attraction to each other
test the waters to see if things will
work out and then ultimately go their
separate ways
that's what happened to joe jonas and
demi lovato when they met while playing
love interests on the hit disney channel
movie
camp rock in 2008 demi has gone on
record saying that she quickly fell in
love with joe when they shared a few
scenes together while filming
and watching the chemistry between the
two of them in the final cut of the
movie
you can tell they really liked each
other but sometimes acting opposite of
someone you like
can be awkward as demi has explained
their very first kiss was a stage kiss
on camera and although the two started
dating shortly after that they didn't
stay together long
dimmy says it may have been for only a
month or two but there were no hard
feelings about the breakup
they still remain friendly and
supportive of each other even today
how nice ian somerhalder and nina debrev
nina dubrev has stated in the past how
she did not want to date co-stars
we understand that it could get a little
messy as one tries to blend both a
professional life and a personal life
that just seems like it could be a
recipe for disaster
but nina had to break her rule when she
met ian summerhalder on the set of the
vampire diaries
in the hit vampire romance show ian's
character is daemon
a handsome immortal being just oozing
with charm
turns out that's not really an act ian
seems just as charming and charismatic
as the character he plays
nina and ian just couldn't deny their
feelings for each other and the two
started dating
their relationship lasted from 2011 to
2013
and although the world may have been
rooting for them to get married
sadly that wasn't the case their breakup
seemed a little tense with ian tweeting
out people change and forget to tell
each other
but that doesn't mean there's any bad
blood between the two of them they
remain
friends to this day which is great the
only real moment of awkwardness
had to have come when the pair won the
people's choice award for best chemistry
but only after they had broken up
zac efron and vanessa hudgen to minnie
zac efron and vanessa hudgins are the
king and queen of the whole disney
channel couples who dated in real life
craze
the two of them met while auditioning
for the iconic high school musical
back in 2005 and their lives would never
be the same
ours either for that matter we could
pick any number of reasons we love the
high school musical franchise the music
the dancing
sharpie sense of style but overall what
really made the franchise special was
the chemistry between
troy and gabriella the two characters
seemed really in love and that's because
the real life actors had developed a
special connection
zach and vanessa dated for close to five
years starting in 2005
and breaking up in 2010 that means they
were dating throughout all three high
school musical films
but why did the power couple break up in
the first place well vanessa has told
reporters that she wasn't in a good
place
she was becoming really mean as she
watched a ton of girls try to pursue
zack
and ultimately she didn't want to be
that sort of person who knows if there's
more to the story but overall the two
seems like they've remained good friends
ever since dub cameron and ryan mccarten
we cheered when we saw dove cameron and
ryan mccarten
co-stars of the hilarious liv and maddie
tv show
actually start dating in real life their
relationship was so sweet on the show
that it felt like a true match made in
heaven
we mean remember the time when liv was
pretending to be her twin sister maddie
and asked diggy to dance for her
but diggy said no because he knew it
wasn't the real maddie
our hearts melted at that moment and
although the two danced around a
relationship for a while
it finally ended up with them together
and happy
but real life didn't happen the same way
the two disney channel stars dated for
three years before getting engaged
although things quickly grew sour less
than six months after their engagement
both of them announced on twitter that
they had gone their separate ways
we don't know how mutual things were
thanks to ryan's specific tweet saying
dove has decided this relationship isn't
what she wants
we still love each other very much
please be sensitive as this is painful
sounds like dove was the one who called
things off but time heals everything as
both dev and ryan have moved on to other
relationships
leah michelle and corey monteith okay we
know that leah michelle
and corey monteith never broke up but we
wanted to take just a moment and
highlight how special these two
relationship
was before it was tragically cut short
the two met on the set of glee and
although it took a while for their
characters to get together in real life
corey and leah knew that they had
something special and started dating
relatively quickly
by all accounts the two had a loving
supportive relationship and it's so sad
that we never got to see its full
potential
rest in peace cory alexis bledel
and milo ventamilia sometimes you just
have to go with a bad boy
if you remember the hit gilmore girls tv
show you probably remember the classic
romance between
alexis bleidel's rory and milo
ventimiglia's jess throughout all their
ups and downs we never did stop rudin
for these two crazy kids to work it out
yes we'll admit it we were way more team
jess than team
dean and maybe it's because of the
chemistry alexis and milo shared on
screen
milo joined the cast of gilmore girls in
the fall of 2001
and it wasn't long before the two struck
up a romance of their own
but it turns out the two were very
secretive about their relationship
generally avoiding the public eye though
just because they kept
things private doesn't mean it wasn't
serious the two dated for four years
that's a crazy long time
overall things didn't work out for the
couple and details are scarce about what
exactly happened to instigate a breakup
and although we're sad they didn't stay
together alexis is now happily married
to
vincent kartheiser of mad men fame
channing tatum
and amanda bynes now here's two names
you would never think would be linked
together
channing tatum and amanda vines if you
remember the two starred together in the
2006 movie
she's the man as a refresher amanda
starred as viola hastings a talented
soccer player who dresses up as her
brother
to play soccer at an uptight prep school
tanning played duke the attractive
soccer team
captain and the two eventually fall in
love although their characters were the
ones who started dating
sparks may have flown behind the scenes
as well
although it was never confirmed
paparazzi had snapped photos of the two
actors
smooching behind the scenes while
filming the movie again
channing and amanda never have gone on
record to say that they were an item
but who knows what happens behind closed
doors and we don't think it was a
general fling either
channing has gone on record saying he's
never been someone who has casual
relationships
but rather has always believed in true
romance we may never know what truly
happened between the two actors but at
least we got a really fun
enjoyable movie out of it taylor lautner
and taylor swift
it's time for the taylor power couple
whenever taylor swift
gets a new celebrity boyfriend it
usually turns a few heads
but one of our favorite pairings for the
grammy award singer and songwriter was
none other than
taylor lautner the famous werewolf with
an even more famous six-pack
the two met on the set of the romantic
comedy valentine's day in the summer of
2009
and that soon grew into a relationship
side note
how weird is it to date someone with the
same name as you that's a pretty rare
occurrence
for a while these two only rumored to be
dating but it was confirmed thanks to
pictures of the two going out to things
like hockey games together
and let's not forget lautner was there
on stage with swift when kanye west
intercepted swift's award
good times so why didn't these two
on-screen lovebirds work out
well a source close to swift said that
she believed there wasn't much chemistry
between the two of them and the
relationship just wasn't going anywhere
but yes to answer your question swift
did write a song about their breakup
robert pattinson and kristen stewart ah
yes the famous
robert pattinson and kristen stewart
relationship
let's just say there's a reason the two
won best kiss at the mtv movie awards
four years
in a row the two's on-screen chemistry
was undeniable and it's because the two
were very much a couple while the series
was going on
while they were together the world was
obsessed with kristen and robert's
relationship which is why it was
all the more heartbreaking to watch it
crumble and we're all sort of aware what
happened right
kristen was caught with her snow white
and the huntsman director
rupert sanders in some compromising
photos and the world was shocked
stewart called the scandal a momentary
indiscretion but it seems like the two
stars just couldn't work through their
problems
and had to call it quits it was probably
for the best but it definitely broke the
hearts of millions of team edward fans
but if anyone really wants to relive
their famous romance
we suggest just go and watch the
twilight movies again
that might ease the pain well that's a
wrap on today's video
what on-screen couple was your favorite
and who do you wish never broke up at
all
i know for us riverdale just won't be
the same without cole sprouse and lily
reinhardt dating
but tell us what you think in the
comments and be sure to hit that
subscribe button for more awesome
content like this
thanks for watching the things